all right hello everyone
um hope you had a great lunch hope you
enjoyed your lunch and also hello to the
remote attendees here today my name is
Susan thank you so much for the
introduction and I'm very excited to be
here today I'm talking about my journey
through four Industries with python
so a little bit about me some of this
which was mentioned graciously I'm the
principal data scientist at elastic I've
built machine learning in several fields
and also I've spoken at various pycons
around the world including U.S India
Canada Taiwan Apec and I'm very very
glad to add this pycon and Pi data onto
that list
a bit of an overview of the four
Industries and what I've learned the
four Industries so there's no surprise
is game development telecommunications
fintech and security
and just to go through a little bit of
the beginning very very beginning of my
python Journey
um a little bit too early but I was in
elementary school and then I played
games in computer class where they were
teaching word and photo editing but
there was no programming so I did some
of the Microsoft Word stuff and then I
was downloading Age of Empires to play
on the school computer so that got me a
little bit interested in gaming but I
wasn't really sure what I could be doing
with programming but that's one of the
first things that I could see myself
making
after that I had my education in
economics at the University of Waterloo
and my Master's Degree at University of
Toronto both of these are based in
Canada where I am from I flew here and
uh ingested just enough caffeine so that
I can beat the jet lag
so the first industry here is gaming
in University I studied economics and
proceeded to play some more games I got
really interested into this field as a
student and there was this type of game
called narrative driven games which
primarily my exposure through them were
through some Japanese games such as the
no Neri games or 999 games on the three
Nintendo 3DS and
one of the key things they have in
common is that they have a text box on
the bottom so for example this one is a
mystery murder mystery game and a lot of
the puzzles and whatnot are narrated
through this text box at the bottom of
the screen
and this type of game uh narrative
sometimes is called visual novel style
narrative it's pretty popular in more
recent games and of course just to call
out it's not only Japanese games that
have them for example in the west
there's long been these like text
Adventure Games as well in the past but
just you know bringing up some recent
popular games that have sold quite well
and I would say that the Pokemon games
might be one of the ways that some of
you have played games that have this
kind of delivery even though I wouldn't
say it's a visual novel game but it has
some hybrid where the delivery is
through this kind of technique and the
gameplay is through other types of
mechanics
and python helped me enter game
development because I started
self-learning while studying other
things in University I didn't take
programming classes apart from one or
two electives which actually did not use
Python but they use a language called
racket or doctor Racket and all the time
on the University forums people are
complaining no one uses racket to work
why are we learning racket but that's
one of the curriculum in University of
Waterloo maybe some of you here have
been familiar with it and maybe have you
know wanted to learn something else
instead but okay to its credit I did
learn a lot from racket
um
but then I was able to take that
foundation and start to self-learn so I
think python has pretty good
documentation and that's really helped
me with uh getting getting started
getting to know things and um just try
and play around with different things
and another part that I enjoy is that
it's object oriented which
coincidentally is really common in game
development if any of you here are from
the game development industry and use
Python it's pretty common because all of
these objects in the game right they can
be they can have specific traits like
the menus have different types of Trades
the players have a specific type of
traits if you have items in the game
such as um like keys or let's say guns
in the game
um like little things like that you can
use class classes to make sure all the
traits are inherited when you create a
new object so actually gamedev is pretty
uses a lot of that thinking and Design
so this is the thing that really got me
to start with python which is rempi it's
an open source
um game engine created by python it's
open source and actually a lot of large
game studios use it as well and also
hobbyists such as those participating in
game jams game jams are the game version
of hackathons
all of all of these have in common
sometimes they use rempi and I think
this is really powerful because I was
able to self-learn through using rempi
and it's actually improved quite a lot
over the years as well since I've been
using it for quite a few years I've got
to seeing it change and I got to see it
go from python 2 to python 3.
um
yeah so pretty nice pie game it's rampai
is built on top of Pi game or uses quite
a large portion of it which is a set of
python modules designed for writing
video games as you can see here feel
free to check it out they also are used
to make a lot of 2D 2D games as opposed
to 3D games I know some people have
tried to hack together 3D as well in pi
game
and I would say rempi is pretty powerful
it has flexible visual effects I'm using
an example here from a game that has
been downloaded like millions of times
it was pretty popular in North America
hopefully this reference can land here
but uh it I'm just showcasing that you
can create some different animations you
can also create different visual effects
and a lot of people share these
animations and the code that they can
use for these these effects
and it's pretty simple to get started
after I talked about rempi at my pycon
us talk um some of the Python core
developers it seemed to resonate with
them mariata said she introduced it to
her kids and then they learned to make a
game in the same evening with rempi and
Carol is also one of the core developers
and then she said her her daughter
previously got started with python I'm
using rempi and so it's kind of a
similar situation for me I got started
using rampai and then now I work in
machine learning so her daughter got
started with REM pie and then eventually
went to do other things
um in the gaming industry so I think I
just wanted to share share that and that
really made me happy
um now on to some code just very very
simple run by is pretty flexible as you
can see here it's just stuff you can
probably read immediately okay import
some random import time we've probably
all done this before and you can see
okay some classes some methods
um so this is in rempi and then I use
this to implement a timer of how long
the player takes to do something so
imagine you're playing a game and then
you're you know there's there's
something that comes up and then you
take five seconds to respond or you take
two seconds to respond so just just
simple stuff and you can do this in just
very straightforward python some of the
code is actually I took these
screenshots very long time ago I think
some of these things that you can see
here like um I think it was python 2
like with the dot format for the strings
but um you can also generate dialogue by
randomly selecting and combining phrases
with python so what this does is like
sometimes in a game you might talk to
the same character in the game and
they're always saying hello hello right
it's kind of boring if they always say
the same thing so you can just use some
random introduce some Randomness there
or let them respond to you like okay if
these conditions are true then they can
say something different
so one example in the game that I made
which is these dogs the Shiba Inu dogs
um is that if the player chooses
something
um the first part of the sentence will
be different each time so instead of
always saying whoa or wow it can say
some other things like interesting or I
love that or things like that and it'll
also um
say how long the player took to make
this action so all of that with pretty
simple python code so that's just an
example of how you can make different
features
so I would say for people who are
interested into trying this out your
imagination is the limit you don't
really need a really high budget you
just need just play around Tinker around
with rimpai
and that's to wrap up a little bit of
this video game Journey right we're only
at one out of four so I'm gonna gonna
try my best here
um I developed this while I was um
studying and then I also developed it
part-time while I was working
um it's actually sold quite a decent
amount of copies and which allowed me to
fund all my future games it was really
really surprising
um I've also released it on various
platforms um Nintendo switch PlayStation
4 and Xbox one I've heard some of these
um consoles and the games on them are
really expensive in Germany so I think
steam is probably more popular but
um I just bring these up because it's I
didn't imagine that because I
self-learned python I could call myself
I could say that hey I have these games
on all of these platforms
and that brings me to part of the next
part of my journey which is I started as
a data scientist building machine
learning models and it came from
something unrelated I had my economics
background and then I also had the
python background that I learned
self-learned because I wanted to make
games while I was a student I combined
the two of them because one of the one
of my friends actually said oh you know
um Python and you know statistics from
economics and you can combine these to
be in the machine learning or data
science field so it was a little bit of
a coincidence but I'm really glad that I
followed my curiosity there so then I
could actually combine those two and go
into machine learning
okay so just some python tools rempi
standard library at the time I learned
of course there was some other things
that I used at the time but just just to
sum it up these are the main tools I
used at the time and I'm still making a
game making games in my spare time on
the weekends and I actually don't
program myself rempi too much anymore
instead I'm training people up and
hiring people to do that so
um
pretty nice next part of the Journey
Keep hiking keep hiking
telecommunications less
um maybe like out of the ordinary but
this is the next part so industry number
two uh Telecom which I will just call
like Telecom or Telco for short when I
was studying economics at the university
University of Toronto there were some
assignments where you could use
different different software such as r
or SAS or something SPSS maybe some of
you have heard of those I think some
people might even be familiar with
Matlab things like that some other
statistical software but I made sure
that I was using python to do these
things so then I could
in addition say that hey I've self
learned some of these things so this is
where I got introduced to numpy or
pandas or tensorflow things like that
and this helped lead me into my first
job in Telco and this to tie into some
of the things that we might
need to use Python 4 in Telco where we
could benefit from using python in Telco
for or including some projects that I'll
I'll bring up in the next slide but just
to give an overview of why and what the
problem space is is Telco could
provide intranet or Mobile phone plans
right like the data you have on your
phone your home phones if you have a
landline things like that those in North
America are all provided by the telcos
and I believe that they also provide a
lot of these Services here as well if
some of these companies are familiar to
you and this is a
the way they have these cables in North
America I I haven't seen anyone yet when
I was in Berlin but I was keeping an eye
out but maybe some of you might be
familiar with these things
um
what happens is that from the ISP the
internet service provider they have all
these cables I guess running underground
or like on the lines and then they will
congregate into one of these service or
utility boxes and then from here all
these cables will then route into your
internet at home so because I was
working at a Telco I was able to see
some of these things and then I kind of
went uh just like tag along onto some of
the technicians rode around on one of
these trucks to people's homes and
that's when you have an internet problem
right you might call your your Telco
like your like Vodafone or something and
then they send a truck to your home or
to your to your apartment or something
so I was able to ride around on one of
those trucks
and one of the
um things that we have in Telco is this
challenge of Fleet availability so this
might be route optimization so one
example is we have a limited amount of
trucks and we have a lot of people they
might be calling saying hey my internet
is down or they might be calling saying
hey can you come fix this things like
that so there's a lot of reasons people
need the trucks to come and there's a
limited amount of trucks and this is a
similar problem but maybe on a smaller
scale than
um some some other types of let's say
delivery or ride share apps where route
optimization or predicting when we might
need much more trucks this would be
useful
and the other one is mobile apps or
websites when we go on the mobile app
for the Telecom to manage our services
or if we want to purchase a new plan or
upgrade the gigabytes that are provided
on our Mobile plan we would use the
website and also the mobile app and
some of the issues here are let's say
the mobile app can be pretty confusing
at times or if the website has a lot of
functionality let's say this user only
has internet services with us but all of
the stuff on the website has you know
Internet and mobile data and landline
and whatever it might cause them to be a
bit confused when they're navigating the
website so that might cause them to be
frustrated if they can't find the
information they need on the website
and the next one is over the top
streaming so what what this is an
example is Netflix or how Disney owns
Disney plus and some other streaming
services the Telecom I worked at in
Canada also owned one platform like this
called crave TV and with it comes
similar problems that
the other over-the-top streaming
services such as Netflix would encounter
which is there's a lot of lot of videos
and TV shows and people might not be
able to have the patience to watch
everything to find out what they like so
one of the things that we would do is
use a recommender system commonly
used by Machine learning and use that to
recommend different topics or different
types of shows to the users of cravetv
and um you can see recommender systems
also on sites such as YouTube or again
Netflix or Spotify where if you log in
it's going to look different than if
your parents log in or if your brother
your sister login it looks different
because it takes into account what you
have been doing on this platform in the
past and then it surfaces up a more
smaller subset that it thinks you might
be interested in
and some of the things I've used in
Telecom for recommender systems and I'm
sure maybe some of the talks in this
conference today or in the next few days
we'll be mentioning a recommender
systems and this is what I happen to use
quite a lot of different companies they
might even use different things I use
scikit-learn which is a common library
that has some tree based models or some
simple machine learning algorithms I
also use spark which people might be
familiar with for data processing but
they also have a pi spark which is a
wrapper around it and also ml lib
machine learning library which I used
for the collaborative filtering
algorithms in recommender systems and of
course I also use Jupiter and other
Associated tools in the python ecosystem
for machine learning
and again for Telecom there's a lot of
those things that we use Python to solve
which is to save our users time and to
ensure that the let's say the fleet are
able to arrive at customers homes to fix
their issues on time because if we don't
do that then their internet's going to
continue to be down and they're going to
be unhappy so that's one of the things
that we're able to use Python and
machine learning to do but in addition
to that it's pretty important to note
that when I was growing my career python
was not enough because Version Control
and other things collaborating with a
team containerization all of these
things I learned as I was doing these
projects and that helped me big build
something that's bigger than myself
because working in a larger larger team
larger company doing larger projects I
needed to collaborate more with people
to make something that not just I'm
capable love but to create something
bigger than myself and that is through
cross team collaboration and learning to
write tests oh I know some folks maybe
some talks here are talking about using
python for testing or Automation and of
course like the ability to break down
tasks into smaller ones were pretty
important too as I continued onto my
career because then I could also help
train up other people and help mentor
and Coach other other developers in my
team
and I would like to say that in my
experience and maybe you all have
encountered this as well which is
software is a living ecosystem that
involves other humans too so a lot of
these other components that are not
python but
um I wanted to bring up
okay uh next third on to the third
um fintech Financial technology
um I'm going to share just just share
some descriptions between the general
Finance industry and also fintech
because I would say that fintech often
takes the foundations of the financial
industry and just wraps it in technology
tries to automate a lot of the things
tries to make some of the more more
boring things and try to make it go
faster so I'm going to some of these
things I mentioned are not exclusive to
fintech but they're also a prevalent in
the financial and banking Industries one
of these is financial forecasting we
also have fraud detection or risk rating
these are things we like to do in
fintech
I'll go through all of those in detail a
little bit the first thing is time
series data and this is common in both
finance and fintech where when we have
the
time series which is let's say a data
set that consists of let's say every
day's data or every hour's data every
seconds data or every week's data right
let's say it's the sales so past days
sales figures like in dollar amounts or
the past week or the past month one of
these things that time series data is
meant to do is forecasting so a company
might say oh what do I think
our sales is going to be in a week or so
um and this could help them make
decisions on okay maybe if we need to if
we project that our sales is going to be
a bit lower or if our seasonality
um so that that means like let's say
around Christmas the sales are going to
increase a lot then we need to increase
um the money we have liquid at the time
so it can help companies financial
companies react faster to seasonal
effects and events so that they are not
caught off guard or they can prevent
fraudulent transactions what this means
is that it's pretty costly right if a
financial institution
gets frotted out of their money like
money is stolen from them right so if
there are mechanisms in place to help
prevent that and that can be in the
method of fraud detection or anomaly
detection etc etc it could prevent
fraudulent transactions and you know
save the customers money and also save
the company money
um and of course like reduce risk of
default on credit so I guess for Banking
and Loans if they're able to I guess
model out whether they will be repaid or
not then they can decide should we lend
this business money or should we lend
this individual money of course there
are some controversies and
um this this method of using modeling
for a risk but I would say that it's
pretty prevalent in all of the banking
around the world they definitely use
some sort of modeling whether it is
machine learning or not or just through
heuristics so the goal of this in the
financial industry is that we can reduce
losses and reduce some missteps here
but another interesting thing I learned
while I was in this financial technology
company is not only you know those those
use cases which are prevalent in the
finance industry but also I'm just you
know learning some more python not
that's not just machine learning which
is
um deploying the machine learning on
demand and this is where some of the
knowledge I have on ML Ops when I was
speaking about it at O'Reilly came from
which is we had to wrap up the machine
learning models into a microservice and
what that means is that if another
microservice that the company has wants
a machine learning result then they
could just feed our microservice the
data and the Machine learning in our
microservice would run and then feed
back the results as a response so this
is one thing that I learned that was in
addition F was also in a startup so what
that means is I had to wear a lot of a
lot of hats by that I mean I wasn't just
doing machine learning modeling I had to
do a lot of other things as well as is
common in startups you might be doing
multiple things that would be different
roles at a big company at the same time
so
just an example is again another diagram
of the same thing which is you might
have other portions of the company or
the other portions of the tech stack
that would be calling the machine
learning through a microservice and then
it would be able to send a response
and some of the things I used here were
um of course like first of all the time
series predictions for financial
forecasting so these would predict
future profit and what not based on the
past sales past sales data past time
series data and these included python
libraries such as stats models or profit
catboost and SK time which is a Time
series that are based on sklearn but
this is only a small small part of the
kind of a stack there I also learned to
use machine learning pipelines and these
are tools that you might be familiar
with kubeflow or ml flow and all of
these have python libraries or wrappers
around them as well
and then next also python for web apps I
know that some people here have worked
with uh several subsets of these but we
primarily use Sanic at this place but we
also tried out fast API which is pretty
hot right now and of course like flask
and Django both of which I have known
people in the industry to use both flask
and Django and I actually think for some
machine learning side projects people
like to use flask and Django because
it's pretty easy to spin up and there's
a decent amount of tutorials on them too
online
okay last one security
all right so
this is where I currently currently am
right now at elastic so elastic we're
known for
um having elastic search which I am
aware that some of the folks in the
audience use and um are the founder or
the creator of elasticsearch shy Bannon
is the CTO of elastic but we don't all
only offer elastic search but we also
have the elastic platform which includes
Enterprise search and observability and
lastly security which is where I am
located or where my team and my
organization is located in and I guess
security is commonly also known as cyber
security so I'm just going to use
security here to refer to that what we
like to do in this industry is detect
malware also anomaly detection or detect
and prevent malicious activity so I've
gone through a lot of things here just a
quick quick recap we want to your game
development
telecommunications and fintech and now
security so I think a lot of these are
okay how did how might python be used in
these industries but also the goal of
this is to to help you or maybe you can
resonate some of these things might
resonate with you with how you're using
python at your workplace but
um it's kind of like I was talking to
someone earlier in the audience or in
this conference that if you ask 10
python developers what they do at work
the there's going to be 10 different
answers right so I'm bringing this up so
that you can also have more data points
and see how you might be able to use
python in your day-to-day or maybe some
of the problems that we're solving in
some of these industries could speak to
your industry as well
and examples of back to security or
cyber security some examples of the
attacks here I'm using very very
simplified language I'm sure some of
these Security Experts in the crowd
could recognize some of these names
um
the first of first of these is living
off the land attack so for example they
could use legitimate Windows services
such as Powershell and things like that
to carry out attacks the second one is
called lateral movement which is let's
say an attacker compromises one of your
corporate employees and then uses that
to gain access to a much more
um
like elevated account which has such
much more permissions and that's pretty
dangerous that's called lateral movement
um
two other examples are data exfiltration
which could be the result of other
attacks which is
um they grab they grab data and then
they they send it else right like so the
example of the last pass
um you know incident is uh kind of
related to data exfiltration I forgot
what other techniques they use but the
result is data exfiltration where the
data that's not supposed to be somewhere
else is sent somewhere else and that's
bad just just bad
um the fourth example could be domain
generation algorithm which is where
malware is waiting for a command and
control center like some types of
malware they're going to wait for let's
say the hacker let's say or to send them
um like a ping or to say okay now you
can download the data or now send a
screenshot take a screenshot of the
compromised user's laptop so but to do
that and not be caught they have to
Generate random domains domains excuse
me to send the data through so then
people who are monitoring it they might
not notice that this is malicious
behavior so it's one way to fly under
the radar and all of these are pretty
bad let's just let's just say I don't
have another adjective for it but on the
security machine learning team I'm on
has deployed a lot of these Solutions on
the elastic security platform and just
an example of General things that you
could use is anomaly detection so a non
anomalous Spike so that means abnormal
spikes in Behavior could indicate an
attack so let's say you have a lot of
logins from a different location that
could mean that someone is trying to
brute force their way into your
company's Network these are examples of
anomaly detections we have in our on the
elastic platform these are not
necessarily made with python but I use
it to show an illustration of what what
anomaly detections for security are
this could be okay like an abnormally
High count of login fails because
because if they're logging in and
failing a lot of times it could mean
that they're trying to boost force a
credential
and the Machine learning part of this
which is another case from the anomaly
detection is using python to classify
malware and we have this in our elastic
endpoint product which is hopefully the
text is not too small but I'll I'll read
it out loud the things that we have in
the data set are examples like the file
header for a certain file or the code
information or the byte information
also whether it's a known malware or a
benign wear benign wear mean not malware
or let's say when you execute this
program if they have a different type of
API call sequence or outgoing packets
right so if we know this about this
program and then run train machine
learning models on it is it able to
detect if a new file is malware or not
and then we use we then deploy this and
use that to detect malware on our
Enterprise customers or actually I
believe there are some free versions of
the endpoint as well on the trial so
just to quickly tie it up here with what
we've used in security xgboost or Eland
which is a way to bring elastic data
into a pandas data frame also the
elasticsearch python client Jupiter
notebook and Associated ecosystem as
well as airflow to orchestrate
data processing
so
python has been really fundamental in
solving a lot of the things I've run
into in every industry right in game
development there's I want to use Python
to create player interaction or
animations or game mechanics in
telecommunications we can use it to do
Fleet optimizations or do recommender
systems on the mobile apps or
over-the-top streaming sites and in
fintech we would like to use it to do
Financial forecasting or fraud detection
or risk rating and in security we can
use it to detect malware conduct anomaly
detection and detect malicious activity
and I didn't actually expect to do any
of these things when I was in school I
was like I I don't know what I'm going
to do Highland tour I'm just going to
make games but now I've done a lot of
these things and python has helped me do
that python has been the tool that I've
used and it's something that I've had in
common through all of these industries
and to be continued
some of the things that I've been
playing around with are just these other
side projects outside of work
um I'm sure there's some talks about
language models and whatnot so I was
also kind of playing around with that
gonna skip through this but for large
language models of course there's some
privacy concerns so I'm just playing
around with it and with data that's mine
and not a proprietary data
and to me python represents potentially
different domain knowledge maybe to you
it represents different domain knowledge
or to you it could represent exploration
and learning like how it has for me and
curiosity and growth and following that
and where will you go with python and
where have you been with python maybe
you'll have so a kind of trajectory like
with these ups and downs and different
places different use cases just like me
and yeah that's pretty much it I'm
writing a book called machine learning
interviews on O'Reilly and I guess it's
semi-related to the things I've talked
about here and that's the end of the
talk and feel free to connect with me I
think these slides might be shared later
at the end so I'm just going to skip
through this and open it up for Q a I
believe
thank you
so thank you very much Susan for sharing
your very versatile Journey with poison
and we got some questions here
how would you rank the different
Industries with respect to the python
code quality you have seen
backpack
wow I I I think it's pretty pretty
difficult so I'm not necessarily going
to rank them by name but just that I've
seen code bases which have much more
with respect to let's say the whole um
let's say devops cycle and a lot of the
things are automated a bit more and
whether that's in python or not I think
those are the best code bases I I work
with
um there are some other things where of
course like as people in data we might
actually start out a prototype that's
like low code quality and low
reproducibility no tests and things like
that right just prototype so it's fine
to have it not you know have tests and
things like that but I I think to rank
them I I've actually seen like different
types of variations of qualities and all
sorts of fields like I mean I know in
Game Dev some of my code is like more
more pretty abstract like modularized
and then some part is like duct tape so
I think there's some kind of like Meme
and gamedas like oh you're a player and
you're playing a game you don't know how
much of it is just like glue and and
tape and just like crappy like you know
things that you hard code and just like
fix
um I've definitely seen that in a lot of
the a lot of the industries as well but
I think it really depends on the the
company and the
um the state of the company as well
right because of course as a startup you
might have more things that are just
like a bit glue a bit like you know move
past and move fast build fast and break
it fast kind of mentality so it depends
a little bit Yeah but I I've seen that
range in all Industries
and what other industry do you see
yourself in future what challenges
learnings do you see there
oh I think a lot of the um interesting
Industries I think the domain knowledge
is harder so for example the same thing
for machine learning is that we always
have some training data or some data
there or we might not even have that but
for example anomaly detection in finance
will use different things that we're
considerate about then anomaly detection
in the security or cyber security Fields
right in finance we might be concerned a
bit more with seasonality so like
holidays and things like that but for
security it's like knowing that well
maybe holidays are important I guess
people have more time on the holidays to
carry out attacks I don't I don't really
know but I think actually in security I
care less about that kind of that
specific kind of seasonality but I care
more about other things so
um that's the part of the question where
like I think that's the challenge which
is the domain knowledge and as for other
fields I think
um I've actually also done some
Consulting before and then I've written
some things for um
different different types of fields so
I've dabbled a little bit in even more
Fields than what I've included but I
guess like nothing really stands out to
me as like this is the field I want to
next but I think that's the thing with
this talk is what I wanted to share that
um with curiosity and with with my
existing
um knowledge in in Python I'm sure
there's a lot more I can learn like
there's there's so much more I have to
do and so much more that I can learn
thank you very very popular question
from game Community how do you ship a
game made in Python to console is
bundling The Interpreter easily
supported on console
oh yeah this is a really really good
question
lots of caveats here so what I did was
actually have a publisher and then they
were the ones that ported the code over
other Indie developers I've seen have
used other engines actually like Unity
or unreal and actually if your game is
more like a very heavy like 3D game then
I do still recommend those and those are
based in c-sharp or C plus plus
respectively but not python but I think
those are more easily ported to consoles
just like in my case the publisher had
that resource to do it for me so I think
that part yeah that's not something that
I that I did alone
thank you
what other languages programming
languages specifically have you learned
on your path
um I've learned some C plus plus because
I was also making a Prototype game in an
Unreal Engine so I've learned a bit of
that
um I would say like that and python are
my main things though because like again
I kind of started with game development
and that was really my hobby of course
like there's various other types of
scripts that I've used throughout my
work like automating things but I guess
like those are kind of shared knowledge
like Linux tools things like that so
shell scripting what what not so I guess
like I wouldn't really that's why I
didn't really count that but I would say
that I'm very very narrow in like on
Python and I don't have like a very
broad range but oh I guess I've also use
like JavaScript and related libraries
when I was doing a Consulting gig to
make a node.js app for a machine
learning purpose so I would also include
that I was paid to do it but I'm not
good at it
um just a second because I've lost my
question
since you've mentioned that your
experience like experimenting with a
large language models and yeah other
advancements in the AI Community how do
you think how generative AI can change
the game development industry
yeah I think that's a really good really
good question and I've thought about it
too I've tried to use it to let's say
generate art assets or to generate
scripts in my personal case I haven't
been able to use it to generate any
usable things
so that's my experience I know there are
some companies that have started doing
this right they're trying to use machine
learning to make like 3D models or
create animations so I think like if
those companies are successful then I
think that would be a more a better
answer to this question but just like so
far from my personal case actually like
all of the generative texts they always
have something wrong just like some
little thing like they just get
something small wrong and I can't use it
without fixing it myself after after the
um after generating it so that's just
been my experience right now I think it
has a lot of potential but as a data
someone a data practitioner I think the
privacy issues are very concerning to me
if I can run all the things locally and
that is possible right that you can
probably run a lot of the models locally
or like just in your own companies like
private clusters but I think there are
some especially like with legislation
like you might not actually be able to
feed like any any data into that so you
might not even be able to use that for a
more robust case but it depends on the
situation just like for my personal
situation I haven't been able to use it
to do the things that I've thought of
doing however I do see potential if the
kind of privacy issues or you know like
let's say you upload like provide your
data to just like say chat gbt or
something right like that's that's not
um private anymore if you upload it it's
touch someone else's server so that
could be an issue right so I think
there's potential but just like you know
everyone has to deal with whatever way
they should protect their own um their
data or that your company's proprietary
code
um that that should be the priority
and final question you link business
problems to all the steps in your career
as a developer how do you prioritize
learning the business requirements as
well as the technical ones
oh yeah that's a good question so
honestly I linked I linked those because
I wanted to show that the code is doing
something right and what better way to
explain it than the
various business cases but I will have
to say like when I first started in
um game it was through like okay you
just want to build things I want to go
from like mine to keyboard like kind of
a kind of mindset and then in Telecom 2
um some of the first projects I did were
just like more more so for learning or I
just happened to be on a project where I
actually just like started you know
coding and doing machine learning I was
like this is so cool and then later when
I had to communicate that to people
because
um what happened was like there would be
some of the higher ups or business
um related folks they're like if we want
to deploy it to real customers you have
to show us like the performance of the
model you have to be able to explain the
performance and things like that so if I
wasn't able to do that then as a
developer my code would go to waste so
then I had to learn that in order to
make my all the technical stuff that I
like to do in order to actually let that
be kind of live and deployed instead of
what I call rotting away in Jupiter
graveyard
um you know like I had to learn to do
those things so that's why like nowadays
I like to lead
um with the problem it's solving but of
course like for example with security
there's a lot I don't know and I think
it's really fun to see some of the
experts on our organization be able to
like they can analyze the files and like
it's pretty interesting how like this
malicious file does this and does that
like that is actually not in my skill
set yet
um
but like if maybe if I wanted to just
like learn something then that's
probably one thing
um that's one thing I would do without
really caring about like the business
aspect so what I mean is that like
because I am on the machine learning
team so then when I think about oh
business impact I should you know be
focusing on the machine learning portion
of it but if I wasn't
um so focused on that then maybe I would
actually try to do a bit more of that to
malware analyzation and things like that
and that's still an option within my
team and my company I just um should I
just like try to balance that out
especially as I'm now responsible for a
larger team of people it's a bit harder
once I started to be more um principal
level at the fintech company and then
now to be like hey I'm just gonna
randomly do this thing and then
um forget about it forget about
everything else and like just just start
to do it but I think that's that's
definitely one one one example of like
maybe just starting with a technical and
then um leading in later with the
business impact but for other I guess
there has been a mix throughout all of
these industries but I think roughly the
time around the Telecom and fintech I
was like okay I if I want my code to be
used like please I have to talk about
the business use cases
thank you we reached the end of the hour
so thank you very much for your talk and
good luck with your career Journey